[Music]
one of the most compelling pieces of
sculpture in cinematic history is the
Darth Vader mask as it appeared in the
first three Star Wars movies it made a
big impression on me as a young child
and I've often longed to own an accurate
replica made to full size now I've
brought some examples of the various
Darth Vader masks this is the dawn post
mask from the 1990s and it is the Empire
Strikes Back version which is a very
gleaming glossy pristine version it has
very soft features it has a large chin
vent it has a very smooth peak on the
dome recently a company in Southern Cal
you for just one brief second yes you
will die alone recently a company in
Southern California called
EFX collectibles released her version of
the 1977 mask and have made it available
in very limited quantity how did you
find out the new 1977 one was available
I routinely monitor the Star Wars
community and then one day you were
probably sitting at your desk I'm gonna
guess in my office not working for me
but scanning some Star Wars obscure a
helmet website when you got the word
from your pal Jub Jub 86ed that oh my
gosh the new helmets are in
it's eerie
[Music]
that more or less what happens these are
benevolent pursuits I spend a long time
and I get a lot of pleasure out of
looking into this mask what kind of
pleasure this sensual sexual sensual in
the sense that it's visual kinesthetic
in the sense that it gives me a sense of
satisfaction do you become aroused when
you put on that helmet yes are you
applying sexually aroused
that's what everyone thinks yes aroused
me not concerned with what other people
think I become aroused why no I know
that you're not concerned with what
other people think that's quite apparent
do you think it's possible and just be
honest that while looking at this you
would ever pleasure yourself
I possible likely possible let me tell
you there is an implication of judgment
here no there's a fan of hearts do you
stare at art do you walk into a museum
and stare at a sculpture a painting why
is this sculpture which is sculpted by a
British man named Brian we're why is
this sculpture any less valid I'm not
saying it's invalid I'm not no you're
completely misunderstanding your it's
finding a judgmental tone to what I'm
saying which I did not intend my
question was very simple when you're
looking at this Halloween mask you get a
jerk off
[Applause]
no judgment come on man have a little
fun you're out let's see the actual
product may we I've kept it in its box I
am having a custom case built for me in
the United Kingdom it will take many
months for that case to be completed and
arrive here in the United States in the
meantime I have kept the product in its
original box and chosen not to take it
out of the box in the interest of
keeping it pristine and untouched okay
can you open the box please to show it
to us now I can show you the box I can
open the box yeah I would not like us to
be in a position where the product can
be at all damaged I swear I won't do
that promise you it your definition of
damage may differ from lies of knife I
don't want your greasy fingerprints on
the map greasy what is that is that like
an anti Irish slam I want your greasy
potato chomping wife-beating mitts on it
is that what you're saying
in fact it's scientific fact our skin
secretes oils those oils keep our body
moisturize in fact oils trap a lot of
the dirt that plagues us the whole point
of soap is it's an emulsifier that
Bond's people I'm stopping you there
because I've been with you and I know
that you're going down a rabbit hole and
we're not coming out for six years so
you tell me what I need to do to see the
mask and not selling it so there you can
see a full-scale replica of the 1977
Darth Vader mask
notice the two-tone black gunmetal
design on the face quite a marvel of
cinematic sculpting you know it looks
exactly like the other ones I've seen I
don't think your view on this matter is
precise may I remove it from the no no
you can't can you
no no I'd like to keep it in the case as
I mentioned that's it you're not gonna
let us take it out no there's no reason
all right let me ask you a question why
am i wearing gloves if you're not gonna
let me even touch it do to your
unpredictable nature it seem like this
is incredibly in a tight climactic we
opened a box we're looking at two pieces
of plastic we can't touch it
we can't display it we can assemble it
that's correct so this magic moment of
television brought to you by Jordan
slansky everywhere I go people ask me is
he real he is 100% real that's him okay
stop asking me
you